this is worth crying
for GL nobody would ever understand how
significant she've been through all the
stuff that we've been through and how
important she is as she's just been the
angel in my life and I owe you
everything um a boys brenon and Nate you
guys would have no idea how valuable
they've been to me because they were the
ones that would give me all the crap
about what I was doing wrong and what I
was screwing up they were harsh and and
their critiques were rash and and the
whole thing it was perfect because I
needed that loyalty and uh they were the
epitome of it for me and forever
grateful they know they know but uh I
don't mind saying it to you um because
it's hard to be that deeply loyal it's
hard to tell people what they don't want
to hear and what they need to hear and
uh it's it's rare to have people around
you that were willing to do that
particularly when you get in this kind
of position and it's so necessary to to
do do well and do right uh fellas love
the hell out of that um Jamie and the
crew uh my daughter and and all are
husbands and wives and our seven plus
kids we got one on the way coming in
April uh making Glenn and I the proudest
Grandma and Grandpa you can be uh really
grateful to those to those kitties that
uh put up with Grandpa's crazy stuff
because you can imagine I'm I'm a I'm a
pretty whacked out
Grandpa